what do you maybe is misunderstood
or a little known about poop
well it's hilarious for one thing yeah
that we do it
okay the word is great as well yes
there's so many different words i do you
know when i'm talking to the parents of
pediatric patients i use the word poop i
don't often when i'm talking to adult
patients trying to choose a more mature
word but um
poop is amazing i mean i guess it's uh
you know it's sort of the most the
dirtiest the most vile the most hated
aspect of our bodies it's the grossest
we don't want to think about it talk
about it have an it anywhere near our
you know food or in social interactions
uh with good reason you know i mentioned
gastrointestinal infections are one of
the most common infections the human
body suffers from and
you know what we call uh the way they
spread from person to person grossly
enough is referred to as the fecal oral
route which is means a bit of someone's
stool is getting into your you're
swallowing it um you know through water
supply
for instance diarrhea is actually quite
a brilliant mechanism of these microbes
right if you let's say you're in the
intestine of one person your goal is to
get into the intestines of another
person
brilliant to just trick their intestines
into secreting all this fluid into into
the intestines to increase the volume of
stool and its runniness so that when
they do poop it gets into the water
supply and then everyone else kind of
ends up getting infected as well wow
just the same way like you know
tuberculosis or coronavirus kind of
infects your lungs and makes you cough
and you send it out into the air and it
ends up in other people's lungs that's
all evolution yeah it's brilliant so
diarrhea is intelligent
is a big takeaway lesson
it's one of the most intelligent things
we can do
as an entirety of an organism not just a
particular cognitive organism but
there's
there's you know we're we're made up of
bacteria and viruses and there's a lot
of visitors and so on as the entirety of
the system diarrhea is one of our better
accomplishments that's fascinating
um well i wonder
why is poop funny
i think a lot of that is socially
constructed just how it's sort of
supposed to be hidden away yet something
we always do something you know we
chuckle about as children and
but even in healthcare you know it
becomes this big topic of conversation
because you end up talking about it
constantly like in the er people come in
i there's complete strangers sometimes
like a nice old lady who resembles my
grandmother and all of a sudden i have
to ask her all about what's happening in
the bathroom like is she straining what
color is it what what you know what's
the consistency
does it float on top of the water more
than it should is it hard to flush i
mean there's a million different
questions you learn
as a as a medical student and you're
like this poop detective when people
come in with issues
and so it's
it's funny i guess you know in the exam
room with the doctor-patient
relationship there's sort of no barriers
you know you talk about everything and
you're talking about the most intimate
details of a person's life even though
you just met them a second ago it's so
different than normal social
interactions yet there is this social
aspect a lot of what i do is social you
know it seems like doctors what they do
is mostly scientific
but actually it's just relating to
another person and you have to
maintain you know your professional
demeanor and this normal human level
interaction even though you're talking
about poop
and that's a skill that's an art and a
science
you